This video is brought to you by Ray con
What's up wisecrack, Michael here.
A lot of you have been very puzzled for a very long time on why wisecrack
composed of many Dan Harmon fans have not covered the other show he made,
you know, the one without the intergalactically drunk scientist,
like our favorite grandfather,
grandson duo community gets extremely meta on everything from Han solo.
I know, but I'm calling dibs on the Han solo role before Jeff slouches into it.
By default to film.
God complexes to the very part of the show itself.
He came back. Would that change your disposition? Sure.
It could get us back on formula, but I don't see it turning us around.
But while one might dismiss the overabundance of references as some weird flex
by the writers room,
I want to suggest that something else is going on the show is trying to tell you
yes, you, that you're much smarter than network television thinks you are.
So how does community manage to do that while also managing to be incredibly
irreverent and silly?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on the philosophy of community and
spoilers ahead for community. And before we get into it,
I want to give a huge shout out to Ray Khan for sponsoring this video.
I only come to the studio once a week for an hour or two to shoot,
which means I spend most of my time home in my apartment with my fiance during
the Workday. I need to watch certain shows for research, of course,
or listen to music. And I just don't want to disturb anyone else.
Rake on ear buds had been the perfect solution. They are comfortable,
discreet and sound just as good as any other premium brand on the market.
They offer six hours of playtime, seamless, Bluetooth pairing,
more base in a compact design for a comfortable noise, isolating fit.
They also come in a variety of colors and styles. So check them out today.
Ray cons also make a great gift because who doesn't need an awesome pair of
earbuds. Now is the best time to get a pair of Ray constants.
Their holiday deals won't last click the link in the description,
or go to buy Ray
con.com/wisecrack to get 20% off your Ray cons and hurries since the offer is
available only for a limited time. Now back to the show,
community follows Jeff winger,
a disgraced lawyer who has to attend a lowly community college in hopes of
getting back to the courtroom.
The state bar has suspended my license. Uh,
they found out my college degree was less than.
Legitimate in the process.
He becomes friends with a study group full of truly bizarre characters.
The phrase cult classic. It gets thrown around a lot these days,
almost as much as the phrase classic cult,
which is often used to describe heaven's Gates, Jonestown,
and people who still watch American idol.
But I digress community is one of the few sitcoms that absolutely deserves this
distinction.
It's a show so beloved that its fans basically saved it from extinction twice.
The creator has his own mythos and documentary,
and it remains a part of the cultural conversation.
Half a decade later with that long awaited movie, maybe still on the way.
One of the reasons for the status is the show's use of references,
which are intricately layered upon each other.
It was about reinvented ourselves over the summer,
a little late to the hipster party, much, a little much on the much, much.
It also makes us in a healthy dose of self-awareness like the bottle episode in
which Ahmed constantly reminds everyone.
That does it starting to feel like a bottle episode.
And this is obviously all really fun, but what if,
and it's over the top use of tropes and references.
The show gives us a unique way to explore the meaning of pop culture and our
relationship with it.
If we want to get a deeper understanding of why clip shows featuring things that
never happened, or a loving fear of LaVar Burton. So.
Do you go to school nearby.
Are actually commentaries on us and how we relate to the media.
We have to look at a thing called Epic theater or interventionist theater.
Epic theater was a style developed by playwright, Bertolt Brecht.
If regular plays wanted people to leave feeling relieved that the hero saved the
day Brecht wanted them to leave the theater feeling very confused.
He was living in an era in which people were consuming, lots of theater,
but the purpose of this theater was to provide entertainment,
not to make people think about themselves and their place in society.
With Epic theater,
he aimed to shift the arts purpose and hopes of broadening its boundaries and
giving it a social function. Brecht criticized arts traditionalist tendencies,
which he thought led to a constant repetition of the same stories and creative
forms. So rather than appealing to the audience's hearts,
like most art of his time,
he sought to speak to their minds that meant using both songs,
placards and projections of ideas onto the stage to hammer home the meaning he
wanted the audience to get these plays.
Weren't subtle works using subtext to convey ideas.
They were intellectual works that put the ideas front and center.
So if he were alive circuit 2009,
he probably would have been sick of all the multicam network sitcoms that
recycled the same themes over and over without ever shaking things up or
exploring challenging ideas. Of course,
Dan Harmon has always seemed similarly bored with traditional sitcom tropes from
his early days of heat vision and Jack into community.
And up through the modern reign of Rick and Morty Harmon has pushed against TV's
tendency to simply repeat what's worked in the past.
And this means that rather than recycling the same tropes that we're used to.
So that watching television is a pacifying experience where our body melds with
the couch and our mind melds with the screen and our mouth belts to the bowl of
pizza rolls covered in CAISO Harmon wants to disrupt our assumptions.
And he does so by subverting criticizing and sometimes just straight blowing up
classic sitcom tropes.
Occasionally that means using the spiritual perfection of chicken fingers to
explore the dynamics of mafia films and the divine silliness of mafia, cosplay.
To us lines are for suckers hacks sheep. We were wolves.
We had the chicken approval.
Sometimes it means using a pulp fiction episode to actually do a,
my dinner with Andre episode.
That explores how we can use film to make human connections.
I chose my dinner with Andre because it's about a guy who has an unexpectedly
enjoyable evening with a weird friend he's been avoiding.
But in both cases,
the show is simultaneously having fun with classic film tropes while also
getting us to reflect on what happens when we can only make sense of our lives
through the framework of these tropes. Indeed,
many of the groups best antics are the result of their inability to think
outside of the rigid box of pop culture. When faced with a basic problem,
the dining hall running out of chicken fingers,
they turn to cultural tropes for their solution. In this case,
that means going full Goodfellas and tearing the group apart in the process.
I don't believe what greedy sellouts you people turned out to be.
I'm not going to stand here and be ignored.
In a less frivolous example.
I've had dinner with Andre occurs when he can't conceive of what a standard
adult dinner would look like outside of a film reference here,
even as attempted normalcy is completely mediated by a work of cinematic
fiction.
All right, so you're ending early because in my dinner with Andre,
the waiter brings.
The show constantly encourages us to think critically about what we're willing
to accept as entertainment and why we're content to watch the same tropes play
out over and over again. We see this in the freaky Friday episode.
If you're worried about Abbott, you should talk to him, right?
I should talk to him.
And which Troy and I buy a six pack of body switching movies.
This of course makes you think how in the hell is this idea of,
and recycled six different times.
13 Going on 30 17, again, 18, again, vice-versa freaky Friday.
But not content to merely roast a tired trope community uses this trope to
create an oddly sweet breakup for Troy and Britta while also bucking against the
inanities of standard sit-com breakups.
Wait, are you breaking up with me?
I think so one of the shows underlying arguments seems to be that the reason
we're served the same slop over and over is that we keep coming back to the
trough without any complaints case in point been in Troy's obsession with the
fictional kick puncher film franchise,
which is clearly a parody of the way the action genre recycles the same
formulaic tropes over and over again. But through this ongoing bit,
we can also see if we're willing to be introspective.
How often we too are just like Troy and Abbot,
letting ourselves fall prey to crappy recycled movies because of the hype.
It's a version of what Brecht was doing with his interventionist style,
making the audience reflect on themselves.
So sure community might not have the same grand ambitions that Brecht had to
change theater so that theater in time could change the world.
But it does seem to have a clear mission to use its extreme mechanism to make
you rethink your own expectations about contemporary media.
And we think Harmon's breakfast.
TV goes deeper than just breaking the fourth wall and offering meta commentary
about culture. See,
one thing that was really important to Brett was making sure his audience was
always aware.
They were watching a play rather than letting them get too caught up in the
action. Similarly,
community never wants you to forget that you're just watching a TV show.
This approach was and remains striking because most entertainment has the
opposite aim, namely,
to make us get so caught up in what we're watching that we momentarily forget.
It's just a performance. This is called the suspension of disbelief,
which means that the audience accepts fiction as reality.
So as to experience the story as real Recht wanted his audience to avoid the
suspension and he did so by having actors purposely deliver their lines
awkwardly,
or even speak directly to the audience community's version of this similarly
breaks, or at least alludes to breaking the fourth wall.
This is accomplished largely via op-ed commenting on the audio.
I use the ballot, starting everyone by popularity,
and I put the most popular with least popular.
I figured it would maximize each partnership's audience appeal.
The more subtly via characters,
discussing plot dynamics and seasons and character.
We'll definitely be back next year. If not,
it'll be because an asteroid has destroyed all human civilization and that's
Canada.
Oh, and Ahmed also plays a cartoon character,
literally named fourth wall subtle by refusing to let us suspend our televisual
disbelief community deflates the significance of standard sitcom tropes.
For example, and friends,
there is an audience expectation that Rachel and Ross just had to get together
for the show to make sense similarly, and how I met your mother.
The show had to jump through some wild hoops to make sure that Ted and Robin
ended up together.
Examples like this dominate modern television and are basically a prerequisite
for having a multi-season run watching community for the first time,
it's a reasonable to expect a romantic payoff between our cocky,
attractive protagonists, Jeff, and the edgy attractive loner Brita.
But because of the spirit of Brett lives on inside the troubled bowels of Dan
Harmon, they get together for a bit and then they split up.
You want to stop doing this? Yeah.
And then she dates another member of the gang and then they split up.
And at the end of the day, none of it matters.
Somebody is sure working our way around the table.
By doing this community. Isn't saying, see, we're not like those other shows.
We're different.
Rather it's challenging the audience to rethink our assumptions about modern
media and how we consume it.
Like why do we immediately expect that the relationship between the two
good-looking people in the pilot will romantically drive the show?
And what does it say about us? And is it a bad thing? See,
it's not just that film and television has created a deep expectation that any
two onscreen stone-cold hotties are eventually inevitably going bang it's that
this assumption bleeds into our real lives,
leading us to assume that meat world friendships and romantic relationships will
also work like the ones we see on screen.
Because while we might think that we're like,
op-eds slowly falling in love with a mystery woman who is hearing impaired,
we're more likely just reading way too much into a friend,
messing with us to prove a point also like outlet and in more ways than just
this,
the character of our bed is really just an exploration of what happens when we
interpret our whole lives through the matrix of film and television.
And while it's funny, when Ahmed does it,
the show often forces us to face up to how dark and lonely this can actually
make our lives. Take the Claymation Christmas episode,
which uses comforting holiday movie imagery to explore ombuds and ability to
cope with real life. Family drama.
Take care of dad, wash your Dupa.
Mommy's moved on new family, new life.
His insistence on real life.
Following a wholesome family filled narrative makes them unable to deal with the
reality that his mother has moved on and now spends the holidays with her new
family.
Or that time gets set up with two blind dates to the Sadie Hawkins dance.
Why don't we.
Pick good girl? And then let Abby decide instead of making it a competition,
that's exactly a competition.
Commitment to the guy on two dates at one stroke. Don't you already.
I have a date to the dance. Yep. Now I have to,
which means I can do the classic two dates in one night sitcom trope,
I'll get to wear two outfits, mix up their names, maybe hide under a table.
Leads him to miss out on the fact that Brie Larson or, you know,
a character played by Brie Larson actually likes him that his friendship with
Troy follows a similar pattern.
He struggles to deal with his buddy leaving to explore the world by boat with
the host of reading rainbow.
So instead of enjoying the last movie night and wishing him well,
he constructs a wildly intense game of hot lava to process his emotions.
He can only deal with a dramatic change once the two friends both die and come
back as clones.
I'm not an exact replication. I have all of our visibilities and memories,
but I'm missing as wild emotionality.
Although I think I may be able to actually go now.
Much of the series. I bet behavior. Isn't really challenged,
at least not explicitly,
but with the introduction of the gruff criminology professor buzz Hickey and
season five, this show gives him a bit of tough love, initiate ballistic.
Oops, what the hell? Sorry. You just destroyed.
Five hours of work.
Was avid to acknowledge that he's using these structures and tricks of cinematic
storytelling to make sense of it.
Life. I know all the tricks and tropes of filmmaking,
but what I'm missing is what I think the critics call substance, but.
There is a problem.
I bed structure over substance problem can be taken as a broader critique.
It asks what happens when our whole lives are mediated via the narratives we
learned from the media. Sure. We know all the tropes,
the plot twist the emotional monologues and the heartwarming conclusions,
but does any of this help navigate our real lives away from the screen?
This seems to be the ultimate Brechtian challenge offered to us by community to
realize that maybe some of the problems in our lives are caused at least
partially by our internalization of the media we consume.
And to realize that the media will keep feeding us this type of thing,
because it thinks that's all we're capable of.
But like the study group we're actually smarter than the TV thinks we are.
As a result, community is able to call both the audiences.
Assumptions in the media is recycled tropes into question and by doing so,
just like Brex theater,
it just might be making us a little more critically engaged and aware.
So next time someone asks you who your favorite early 20th century German
experimental playwright is just scream, Dan Harmon,
and then run away before they can call it into question.
But what do you guys think is Dan Harmon, the new Bertolt Brecht?
Are we all a little bit like Abbot,
let us know in the comments hit that subscribe button,
like you're using the last of your paintballs to defeat your rival college and
ring that bell. Like it's time for anthropology. One Oh one with John Oliver.
Huge. Thanks to our patrons for all your support and as always,
thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].